bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord j'aurais
voulu commenter cette déclaration ce
matin de jean michel bancaire 50 à 70%
la population qui devrait être touché
par le coronavirus est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette probabilité
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il faut être un
être un petit peu plus pédagogique avec
nos concitoyens
quand on dit qu'il y à 4500 cas ces 4500
cas qui ont été dépistés étant donné
qu'aujourd'hui on ne dépiste plus que
les formes graves
au début on a essayé d'endiguer de
confiner dans certaines régions donc on
a essayé de faire du dépistage
directement des personnes à risque
aujourd'hui on ne dépiste plus alors
qu'on a des centaines et des centaines
de cas suspects de coronavirus chez qui
ce sont des femmes tout à fait bénigne
avec des syndromes fébriles
donc il faut encore une fois que les
gens ne compte pas comme ça en sus au
compteur en se disant il ya 4515 que je
suis le prochain probablement vous avez
déjà été en contact ou urine et un petit
syndrome fébrile en ayant été atteint et
ceci n'est pas grave
le danger est pour les personnes
vulnérables et les personnes âgées
surtout qu'ils sont les premiers à
risque de faire des formes graves donc
il n'y a pas en soir 1
il ne pique aux as a créé autour du
chiffre de 70 % d'une contamination de
nos concitoyens puisque c'est le lot de
l'immunité comme pour tout un tas de
virus peut ce soir la gastro entérite
larribe la varicelle etc
et parmi les 4500 cas dans le pays 3 100
dans un état grave dont la moitié au
moins de 60 ans comment est-ce qu'il
faut interpréter encore une fois ces
chiffres puisque vous l'avez dire
l'instant ce sont les personnes âgées
les plus vulnérables celles qui
présentent des pathologies dont qui ont
le plus de risque justement de souffrir
de ce coronavirus oui effectivement ce
sont les personnes vulnérables qu'il
s'agit de protéger
et effectivement les premiers
les premières études montrent que ce
sont en premier lieu des personnes avec
des insuffisances respiratoires de
l'hypertension les maladies
cardiovasculaires et les personnes âgées
qui effectivement se retrouve avec des
formes graves
on a à passer des messages de collectif
inter hôpitaux et les professionnels de
santé ont fait aussi passer le message
c'est les plus jeunes de ne surtout pas
s'automédiquer avec des
anti-inflammatoires c'est un message à
faire passer à la population puisqu'on a
remarqué qu'il y avait pu avoir une
aggravation de la teinte lorsqu'il y
avait eu accès aux anti-inflammatoires
avec des prises non fait des non
prescrites par les médecins donc il faut
surtout pas nous prendre d'anti
inflammatoires à son domicile
lorsqu'on est touché s'en tenir au
paracétamol et prévenir les
professionnels de santé ou le 15 en cas
de symptômes qui paraissent urgent soit
difficultés à respirer vomissements
déshydratation ou aggravation de sa
symptomatologie de base lorsqu'on a déjà
des comorbidités associées
alors c'est vrai tu manges d'un tweet
dans les ministres de la santé les
révérends a donc déconseillé l'usagé
quand vous venez de dire des anti
inflammatoires par me fais fait
médicaments anti inflammatoires
il faut quand même les distinguer il ya
des des deux par exemple doliprane
l'ibuprofène enfin pas le doliprane je
crois que le doliprane c'est possible de
l'utiliser c'est ça vous m'entendez
oui oui donc je disais par rapport aux
anti inflammatoires est ce qu'on peut
être ce que vous pourriez nous préciser
un peu plus sur le type de médicaments
qu'il est possible d'utiliser ou pas
justement non il faut bannir ou les anti
inflammatoires
il n'y a pas un choix à faire les
prescriptions doivent être uniquement
faite par un médecin et on ne sait pas
de choix entre différents anti
inflammatoires
les gens qui en ont de manière chronique
à ses très rares
les anti inflammatoires en général c'est
surtout pour des pathologies ou bénigne
traumatologique une entorse de choses
comme ça
pour le reste il n'y a pas
à ce que les patients fassent eux mêmes
un choix entre la ville et prochaine on
peut c'est juste pour balmy tous les
soutiens femmes à thoiras n'ont pas été
directement prescrit par votre médecin
on s'en tient en paracétamol toutes les
six heures pour les syndromes fébriles
et effacer la cortisone par exemple on
sait qu'ils souffrent d'asthme ou
d'autres pathologies respiratoires la
cortisone et données de la même façon
elle n'est absolument pas comme les anti
inflammatoires disponible en vente libre
en pharmacie ainsi doc les prescriptions
de doivent être prolongées et ou
maintenu uniquement sur la prescription
de son médecin traitant
un asthmatique qui a du mal à respirer
et qui a un syndrome fébrile
même si d'habitude il prend lors des
crises d'asthme à du sol près il ne doit
pas le prendre sans avis de son médecin
comme il le fait d'habitude il faut en
fait s'en tenir aux choses habituelles
et bannir l'automédication qui est par
ailleurs même en dehors du courant
navires us un fléau dans le dans le pays
de gens qui s'auto mehdi d'antibiotiques
de corticoïdes ou d'anti inflammatoires
rien en dehors de prescription de votre
médecin traitant des urgences ou d'un
autre médecin via la téléconsultation
etc
alors vous travaillez aux urgences
quelle est la situation aux urgences
actuellement est ce que comment se passe
justement le les soins alors moi je
travaille aux urgences médicales de
paris donc ce n'est pas un service
hospitalier c'est un service qui
intervient en urgence au domicile
effectivement relié avec le samu les
pompiers et les hôpitaux de paris
aujourd'hui nous sommes déjà en
saturation il ya plusieurs problèmes le
problème numéro un c'est que nous avons
un risque d'être potentiellement
vecteurs nous les médecins fils car nous
n'avons pas été équipés nous avons
prévenu les agences régionales de santé
depuis presque deux mois que nous avions
besoin d'équipement malheureusement nous
n'avons pas reçu le moindre masque
nous avons réussi la semaine dernière
quelques uns à se procurer
des masques du stock de pharmacie
malheureusement une seule boîte de 50
personnellement j'essaie huit pharmacies
avant d'en trouver une
et en voyant 15 patients par jour et en
devant s'équiper soi même et qui par le
malade une boîte me fais deux à trois
jours maximum
donc on est obligé de contourner les
consignes de garder le même plusieurs
heures de le fermer de le mettre dans sa
poche et de le réouvrir à la
consultation d'après nous n'avons
malheureusement pas de sur blues nous
n'avons pas reçu de stock de gel
hydroalcoolique supplémentaire donc ça
pose des vrais soucis dans la mesure où
nous allons voir de nombreux patients
suspect d'être coronavirus un de nos
médecins à d'ailleurs été atteints est à
ce jour en 14 n 1 de nos confrères
pardon et nous allons ensuite chez des
patients qui pour le coup sont à risque
des insuffisants respiratoires des gens
qui ont des cancers des gens qui on sait
des problèmes cardiovasculaires ou des
insuffisants respiratoires chroniques
sous oxygène donc c'est là on nous
alertons le ministère de la santé et les
autorités il faut urgemment que la
médecine de ville et il en va de même
pour les infirmières libérales pour tous
les gens qui vont chez les patients pour
soient protégés afin de ne pas être des
vecteurs et de risquer de contaminer
nous mêmes nos patients sans quoi nous
augmenterions les formes d'aggravation
chez les personnes fragiles et ensuite
nous risquerions d'ajouter à la
difficulté des hôpitaux dans les
services de réanimation
si nos patients venaient à s'aggraver et
aujourd'hui donc les informations que
nous avons sur le terrain de nos
confrères hospitaliers sont
effectivement assez alarmante pour ce
qu'il s'agit de certaines zones c'est à
dire que dans le grand test nous avons
déjà des témoignages de saturation des
services de réanimation
nous avons une saturation du numéro 15
donc là aussi il faut de toute urgence
je pense que le gouvernement et les
autorités fassent des appels pour bien
préciser quels sont les cas dans
lesquels il faut appeler le numéro 15
c'est un numéro d'urgence
et quand on a un virus ou pas les gens
continuent de faire des infarctus de
faire d abaisser de faire des péritonite
il faut après
en que ce numéro puisse continuer à
sauver les cas d'urgence vitale ce n'est
pas une ligne d'information
donc là aussi il faut absolument voilà
sur ces points-là équipements de la
médecine de ville
redéfinition des priorités de soins et
d'accès aux urgences pour la population
semblent être des paramètres que les
autorités doivent gérer de toute urgence
et sur les mesures qu'on a lancé
justement le cas les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement et la gestion de la
crise un plus globalement du coronavirus
par ce même gouvernement qu'en pensez
vous est-ce que par ailleurs on un
scénario à l'italienne
vous ne craignez scénario à l'italienne
ou pas écoutez en ce qui me concerne moi
je lis et les premières remontées quand
je vois des témoignages comme ceux qu'on
voit qu'ils sont mis à jour peu près
toutes les heures par le collectif
intéressant c'est collectif inter
hôpitaux qui reçoivent les témoignages
de leurs confrères partout en france
bien sûr qu'on craint scénario à
l'italienne dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui sont déjà en train de devoir
choisir quels patients ils peuvent
mettre sous assistance respiratoire ou
pas non pas en fonction de la personne
mais surtout en fonction des moyens
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
ventilateur ils n'ont pas assez de
matériel d'intubation et de matériel
respiratoire
pour m tous ceux qui le nécessitent réçu
d'assistance respiratoire
donc évidemment ensuite comme nous le
disons depuis plusieurs années cette
crise n'intervient pas n'importe quand
elle intervient dans un contexte tendu
depuis des années dans l'hôpital public
nous avons fait plus de 11 mois de grève
sans avoir une seule une seule de nos
revendications qui est été écoutés donc
aujourd'hui nous avons aussi des
hôpitaux qui fonctionnent qui était déjà
en dessous nous en sous-effectif
donc nous avons pas assez d'être
soignants pas assez d'infirmières passé
nous regardiez pas assez de médecins
puisque les gens sont partis de
l'hôpital successivement pendant des
années donc cette crise voilà
n'intervient pas n'importe quel moment
il faut à tout prix trouver des moyens
de faire des ouvertures de lits en
urgence comme c'est déjà le cas mais il
faudra aussi
par tirer les leçons a posteriori de
cette crise et se rappeler que le
service public est indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de l'état et qu'il ne
peut pas avoir vocation à répondre aux
impératifs du marché ou aux impératifs
d'une rentabilité dogmatique
merci beaucoup sabrina ali benali je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin aux
urgences médicales de paris merci pour
cette intervention en direction article